[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is the host of the fine
print a ramsey networks production on
podcast that has just ended its first
season there are what 10 12 episodes
yeah we got 11.
we had a bonus one for the bard future
documentary release
okay perfect very good well be sure and
check that out folks there's a little
bit of everything there when you read
the fine print uh you will know why
you're getting screwed george will help
you do that you can't say it's a
feel-good show but yeah it's it's it
feels it feels good to avoid pain and
you're good at helping them do that so
there we go hey you guys want to talk
about your life your money your work
your relationships we're here to help
it's what we do on the ramsay show the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five ryan is in bismarck north
dakota hi ryan how are you
i'm doing well sir how are you better
than i deserve what's up
uh so
my question is i'll start with that um i
just need to know kind of what to do
so right now i make about 25 000 a year
and i am getting government assistance
from medicaid and food stamps and
uh government housing and stuff like
that
um and
if i make any more
then all of that goes away
and
if i make
more then i have to cover all of that
which would be about 1500 a month
roughly so i would have to get another
job
to
make ends meet with that but i'm barely
making ends meet with it as i am now so
i guess my question would be should i
get another job and make more money or
should i kind of stay where i'm at and
kind of try and figure out where i can
go from here
where do you want to be in five years
and how is the short what's the best way
to get there
um basically i just want to be able to
spend the money that i make
you know i don't want to live paycheck
to paycheck and struggle through life
barely surviving i just want to be able
to you know what i'm i've made this
money i get to spend it hell i want
i'm not monetarily driven
so i don't necessarily want to be a
millionaire if you will
but uh i mean that would be nice but i'm
not super like i need to be a
millionaire in this many days
okay
well it's not the million dollars that
matters um it's what it does
it's not the uh the pile of money
whatever pile size pile money you want
to deal with that matters it's what it
does it gives you
freedom it gives you uh security it
gives you the ability to help others
none of which you have right now
if you take the government assistance
out of the picture and you called in and
said hey i made twenty five thousand
dollars should i keep making twenty five
thousand dollars or should i work so
that long term i can make more than that
and have control and have less anxiety i
would tell you to go get that other job
you're not going to be working multiple
jobs forever right
hopefully
you're going to find a job in a field
that you enjoy hopefully are you able to
do the kind of work that you want to do
um actually right now i'm detailing
vehicles and i kind of enjoy it you know
and that kind of means more to me than
a high-paying job is kind of enjoying
what i do why can't it be both you know
can't you detail cars and make a great
living
you're not wrong
there's a guy in my neighbor who charges
you know 300 bucks to detail a car he
can do two cars in a day
you can make a lot more making a lot
more than 25 000 yeah
and so to me i was working for somebody
else detailing cars are you doing them
yourself
uh no i'm working for a company
okay
okay so let's and i i just make 25 000
because that's kind of my cap for
my medicaid and that kind of stuff
okay
so here's the thing
as long as you use the government
assistance
psychologically not a moral statement
but psychologically as a reason not to
go be successful
um then it's a bad thing we we want for
you ryan for you to be successful and
prosperous and have a really quality
life how old are you
uh 30 and i've got two babies okay all
right and so if i woke up in your shoes
what would i do and that's the way i
answer questions george answers
questions here on the show
um yeah you gotta feed your babies
that's your first thing
uh number two it is
valid that we do want to do something we
have some passion about and and are
working towards but what i don't hear
from you and you couched it under i'm
not monetarily driven is i don't hear a
lot of ambition
um and i want to give you a little bit
of that i want to inject a little into
you because of what it will bring to
your life
uh in other words i i would say let's
let's start setting some goals like i
would love to own my own detail company
uh by
uh 12 months from now because it really
doesn't take that much it's a pressure
washer and a thing of rags right and so
it's a little bit of a solvent so i mean
you can do this and so and then you need
some clients and and make a lot more on
your own as a mobile detail guy with a
cheap pickup and a pressure washer
thrown in the back and whatever it takes
for you to go do that it does not
require a bazillion dollars in equipment
to start this business
and and let's go make 60 70 000 a year
doing that
instead of saying well i'm afraid if i
make a dollar more i won't get this
uh government stuff and so i'm kind of
trapped you're not trapped the only
thing only trapped you are is between
your ears
yeah that's a good word and ryan i think
you just need to set some of these goals
like dave's talking about and find that
passion because i think once you find
that if that's auto detailing that's
great go after that and don't you the
government assistant's going to be in
the rear view mirror soon as you start
to make some great money with this and
you can make this maybe one day a
full-time gig
i mean it's not that you need to quit
the government assistance today but i
would set a goal that by the end of the
year i've changed my career i've changed
my job i've changed what i do or how i
do it to where i don't need the
government assistance anymore you do not
want to set your life up to where you
have a permanent depend on the
government because it's not going to
create a good life for you
there's you just don't meet people and
go oh you know i'm the happiest guy in
my life i mean i'm the happy scandal
where i spent 50 years in subsidized
housing it just
made me just made my life awesome this
these are not things that people say
dude
so yeah this is a thing you've got for
today and then you need to have a plan
to move away from it for your own
dignity your own prosperity your own
security
and your own growth your own personal
growth uh and so
it's a it's a good thing hey man i
appreciate you call i'm honored to have
you in the audience if we can help you
anyway let us know let me send you a
copy of ken coleman's book if he'll read
it kelly tell him make sure he'll read
it it's called from paycheck to purpose
from merely collecting a paycheck to
doing something with your life that has
purpose and oh by the way what george
said is exactly right
it's not mutually exclusive that you
have to not make money in order to be
happy as a matter of fact it's usually
quite the opposite when you're happy you
tend to make more money
that's the way it works
it's not just being a greedy capitalist
or something that's not the point
it's not a greed thing it's a i want to
feed my babies and have some security
and have some choices
thing it's a freedom
thing
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in just nine days george next week on
thursday january 13th we've got a huge
free
live stream event
coming it's called build wealth in 2022.
we've sold out of in-person tickets over
1500 people will be joining us live
in the audience and uh over 50 000 have
already signed up for the live stream
it's called building wealth in 2022
thursday the 13th of january if you
haven't heard us talk about it yet
rachel cruz george campbell and i are
going to be talking about building
wealth in 2022 we're going to talk about
the latest greatest get rich quick
things we're also going to talk about
how to really build wealth we're going
to talk about how to become a baby steps
millionaire and we're going to show you
how to become wealthy the quickest and
surest way
nine days you still got time to sign up
it's a free live stream you go to
ramseysolutions.com
wealth george i was going over the
content of that event with the
production team this morning
it looks like you've got some pretty
cool things to say oh yeah i'm really
this is something that's near and dear
to my heart because the people that i'm
talking to that are in their 20s and
their 30s they're not asking me hey how
do i pay off my student loans they're
going i don't have any margin in my life
i need to go get rich i need to go
invest in nfts and crypto to make a
quick buck and i just want people to
slow down understand what these things
are really listen to the ramsay plan
that changed my life that allowed me to
have the margin that they're looking for
and again it all points back to our
principles but there's this piece on the
top that's all the trending topics that
everyone's really freaked out about am i
gonna have fomo because i didn't get in
on bitcoin at the right time and you
know this because you talk about it and
babysits millionaires
the path to get rich quick is a it's a
dark path and it can end very poorly and
the slow path being the tortoise is the
way to do it and that's what we outline
in the book of all of these stories from
people who did it the slow way and they
actually kept their wealth
january 13th sign up it is a free live
stream and it'll be george campbell
rachel cruz and me
talking about building wealth in 2022.
it is real and you know back to our last
caller for a second it's worth
saying we have never in the 30 years
i've been on the air or doing books or
been on stage none of us at ramsay have
ever told you to
become wealthy
just to become wealthy or to become
wealthy because it's going to make you
happy it won't
um
but but this idea that being poor is fun
or being broke is fun
is asinine
it's not fun
i mean i've been both i'll take i'll
take money you know but it's not i mean
you got a headache you can afford dead
gum advil you know but but uh
but but
but on the other but but you can't
uh opt out
of bothering to handle your money well
in the name of i don't want to be greedy
because we've never told you to be
greedy no we've never told you to
uh
you know to that that money's gonna make
you happier that money's all that it's
not money has absolutely no value except
what it does what it does do is it puts
shoes on your kid's feet
what it does do is pay the light bill
and keep the heat going
what it does do is give you the ability
to retire with dignity not counting on
someone else to take care of your old
butt
you know
what it does do is give you options to
feed hungry children i've never met
broke people who feed hungry children it
doesn't happen by the way unless they're
spooning food out that a rich person
bought to give away
so you know this idea that somehow
wealth is bad and it's not a
valid goal
to go after
is um
is a cop-out
yeah and you've said this before money
makes you more of who you already are so
if you're if you're a great virtuous
person who's generous you're going to
become even more generous when you have
money but that's a lot harder to do when
you're broke and so if wealthies is evil
then the opposite is being poor is
virtuous it just doesn't really make any
sense
no there is no virtue in poverty that
that's there's nowhere
in scripture that says poverty is
virtuous
or that poor people are more virtuous
than rich people as a matter of fact i
was just doing a podcast with a young
man this morning
i was a guest on his show
and we're talking about this that the
ratio
of evil jerks
is about the same with rich people as it
is with poor people
there's just a ratio of evil jerks out
there
and you know a percentage of the public
is just evil jerks they just fall in
that bucket
and then there's the rest of us
and some of us are you know okay some of
us are a little better than okay but the
evil jerk bucket is about the same
regardless of the poor or whether you're
rich
and so this idea that somehow it makes
you virtuous to be broke is ridiculous
and that's why i love the so that and we
talk about this a lot on the show we we
build wealth so that not just for the
sake of piling up money because we can't
take it with us it's so that we can have
an amazing impact on our families and
our communities um and leave a legacy
yeah it's you know what it's
the only thing that money's good for is
so that
that's all it's good for
you can't be outrageously generous
if you don't have outrages
outrageous starts at that sentence i
mean you gotta you gotta have the
outrageous part to be outrageously
generous and that's the stuff that
inspires us all yeah and it's also the
most fun you're gonna have with money
selfishly
more fun than buying stuff get you some
stuff stuff's fine i love giving away
your money dave it's a good time you
you've kind of developed that into an
article that's my personal brand it's a
spiritual group of spiritual gifts
that's what it is yeah you have to
spiritualize it god told me that's right
yeah open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money and your work and your
relationships it's what we're here for
connor is on the line in ocean city
maryland hi connor how are you
good sir how are you guys know better
than we deserve man what's up in your
world
all right so i got a little bit of a i
don't know if i'd say a predicament i
just started listening about a month ago
um i've paid off my car since then i
have twelve thousand dollars in student
loans that i plan to pay
as soon as they allow me my provider
just got bought out i don't have the
information to pay those off yet cool
we'll be able to do that this week
though wow um once that's done i'll have
about 65 000 in the bank um
and
in may i plan on purchasing a home i
just kind of want to run that by you um
so basically three options i can buy
uh like a small town house uh real
estate's really expensive just like
everywhere i guess but right now here
it's kind of crazy
um my thought process with that would be
i would live there and then you know as
i grow with the family and stuff i would
keep that as a rental possibly or i
could spend a little bit more and get
you know a single family house that
would
probably last me longer
i'm or do i just keep running with how
crazy the market is you're single
i am yes sir what do you make
uh this year i made 78.
good good for you well done
okay
um
i i would buy the townhouse personally
make sure you have your emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses left
out of that 55k rest of it's your down
payment put as much down as you can put
down um and
here's why when you get married someday
you're going to discover you bought the
wrong house
and so you're going to get the
opportunity to move
and but you will have made money on the
townhouse
yes sir
okay
and and in the meantime you know you've
not been
uh overshadowed by the and you you just
sell the townhouse and buy the next
property we don't keep it and keep a
rental property in debt when you get
ready to move later but but uh
i that's what i would do i don't know
george you got a townhouse right yeah
i'm still in a town home here and we're
gonna upgrade one day but i would not do
investment properties unless you're
doing it with cash which means you've
got a paid for town home first then
you're saving up and if you want to do
that later on in life but right now
focus on getting rid of that debt get
the emergency fund in place stack up as
big of a down payment as you can we like
20 down or more to avoid the pmi
and then make sure that it's a 15 year
fixed and the payment is no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay that way
you're gonna have margin to do all the
other steps like save for college and
cash flow the wedding and pay off your
house early and all the other great
things that come along with this plan
yeah they'll that stuff will all happen
later but right now we'll just make you
a real estate owner
and uh on a reasonable payment and hey
start working towards paying that thing
off the more of it you got paid off of
course when you sell it the more you're
going to put down on the next property
that you buy and you move towards
getting your personal residence paid for
and then move towards saving up to pay
cash for
for investments later but i like your
plan i like the way you're thinking and
you jumped right on it man he took
impressive control boom boom knock it
out had a little cash there and started
using it to clear up the debts cleaning
tidying up the house
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage andy and april are with
us hey guys how are you doing good how
are you welcome welcome good to have you
where do you live
we live in raleigh north carolina oh
cool welcome to nashville how much debt
have you paid off
a hundred and forty thousand dollars
how long did this take 24 months way to
go and your range of income during that
time about 180 okay start and finish
yeah what do y'all do for a living i'm a
cost accountant
i work in a tire center oh okay cool
excellent so what kind of debt was this
one hundred and forty thousand dollars
our house you paid off your house
looking at weird people
i love it guys y'all how old are you
guys i'm 39 37 and you're not even 40
with a paid for house wow unbelievable
way to go
very cool thank you so you pay for house
supposed to be old people's stuff but
they're not old people not not on this
stage i like it well done man well done
so what's this house worth
over 400 000.
[Laughter]
way to go
way to go you guys all right tell us the
story what in the world happened to
cause you to want to pay off your house
how did you connect up with all this
ramsey stuff
so a friend introduced me to your
podcast about seven years ago and that
was the first time i heard somebody in
their 30s pay off their house and
realized oh wow we could do that
so when we never thought of that before
i know exactly so when we bought our
house uh over five years ago we decided
we got a 15-year fixed-rate mortgage and
we were like we're definitely doing it
before 15 years and wouldn't it be great
if we did it before
either of us turned 40.
so after we cash flowed renovations we
focused on paying off the mortgage and
we did it i love it wow so have you guys
been following this plan for a while
have you been out of consumer debt and
doing this stuff for a long time
uh so when we first heard the podcast we
had a car payment but we had the money
to pay it we just were like well it's
normal to have a car payment
but when i found you and realized well
let's just not have a car payment not
new yeah
we paid that off and um still had money
as our baby step three and ever since
the kids were born we were paying for
their college and we've always been
investing so the next step was the
mortgage just write down the baby steps
that's incredible well done
well done and you're both numbers people
i mean you heard more than me yes yeah
but cost accountant then you said your
what tire center a tire center i thought
she said tax okay okay all right so wow
all right so she's the number's nervous
for sure she's the brains of the
operation all right well that's okay we
can we can all claim that but
uh man very cool you guys so do you guys
just decide all right if we just live on
this much the rest can go towards the
house we can do this whole thing in 24
months was that the goal yes exactly he
teases me because i love spreadsheets
and so i had a spreadsheet that said if
we paid this each of the months we knew
we were good and
um but on paper you went well no we can
do this if we just follow what's on the
paper on the spreadsheet yeah wow i mean
i'll tease you about your spreadsheet
too but you got to pay for a house
37 years old who's making jokes now yeah
spreadsheet yeah
that's incredible pretty cool so were
there sacrifices along the way for you
guys as you were on this journey i mean
obviously you could have done a lot of
things you have a great income you had
no debt people are people going what are
you doing paying off your house early
oh yeah there was lots of things we
could have gotten to go do instead of
but
yep but we just helped each other stay
focused and the kids helped us um they
didn't get to do you know all the
different activities and stuff because
we said you know if we just put it
towards the mortgage then we're done and
then you can do any activity you want to
do so what's the big thing you're going
to do now that the mortgage is paid for
well we're want to see all 50 states
before there you go our oldest graduates
high school so there you go
yeah and you're young and they're young
kids and now you have the money
because you don't have any debt
to travel so tell me yolo people
they got you butt whipped right here i'm
just telling you this is amazing
yeah
very cool you guys
very cool i just love it i mean it's
just
you are living like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else you truly have have paid the price
to win so what do you tell people when
they find out god you guys are so you
paid off your house how did you do that
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is
make a plan and stick to it
and i think every dollar really helped
because um before you guys had that i
did my spreadsheet
and i could see it every day but he
couldn't so now with every dollar we
both have it on our phone so we both
knew how we were doing throughout the
month and it was great yeah you both
stay that unity that working together
having a game plan having a budget
having a tool like every dollar to work
with
for those of you that don't know that's
the world's best budgeting tool happens
to be produced by ramsey but yeah you
guys are incredible i'm so proud of you
thank you how does it feel to not have a
payment in the world it's awesome it's
so nice so freeing how much is in your
retirement accounts
over 500 000.
so you're you've you've hit millionaire
status then
you're you're uh your baby steps
millionaires yes and you're not even 40.
they're kind of embarrassed about it i
know that's cute i'd be cheering right
now you guys are amazing
yeah
that's what we do right there we should
put them in the baby steps millionaires
book this
did you guys ever think this was
possible i mean when you when you
graduated college or whatever it was did
you think 40 i'll have a paid for house
and i'll be millionaire oh god no no no
i never saw that
so awesome it is it is yes are you the
only people in your sphere that are like
this or are there others have you
inspired anyone else
we try to inspire family i don't know if
they're sticking to it or not
family is the toughest one i found to
get on on board yeah but man they're
looking at you going so they knew you
were weird and now you just proved it
yeah
i love it you guys are amazing you're
amazing well congratulations thank you
so much so very stinking cool man it's
just what and go see those what's the
first step big state what's the first v
the first travel
we're uh going to utah in a week okay um
see some national parks and
ice castle for the kids and yeah
yeah we have about 19 states under our
belt so yeah that's impressive so are
you guys homeschooling and to be able to
do this
are they traveling with you are they in
and out and traveling when they can and
we have year-round schools so when they
do traction yeah yeah we'll hit park
city and go down the slopes yeah all
right while you're there park city is
beautiful when you're in utah yeah
excellent well done guys
all right we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is where you
are that's the next chapter in your
story and you are already reading it
baby i love it well done book comes out
next week but we're gonna give you an
advanced copy and uh of course we're
gonna give you a copy total money
makeover for you to pay it forward and
give to someone and disturb their lives
i'm so proud of you you're such a neat
power couple what are the kiddos names
and ages
claire is 10 and connor is eight okay
now the big question claire and connor
is have you been practicing the debt
free screen
yeah yeah they're both yeah
yeah
they're dialed in they've all the way
from raleigh to get this right so and
maybe maybe a few months before that so
good stuff you guys um man you all are
just neat thank you so much i'm so proud
of you thank you so happy for you that
you're gonna get to do all these things
and be all these blessings to your
family it's just very cool
all right it's andy and april claire and
connor from raleigh north carolina get
ready 140 000
paid off in 24 months that's house and
everything oh and by the way baby steps
millionaires making 180 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three
two
one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
yeah george wow my face hurts from
smiling that's why i keep coming down
here man 37 year old millionaires bring
it baby just like that bring it baby i
think you need a new book baby steps
multi-millionaire we should call it baby
steps millionaires by the time you're
40.
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today a week from thursday we'll
be doing the building wealth in 2022
free live stream if you want to view it
it's free did i mention it's free i
think you can afford it it's free
check out ramsey solutions dot com
slash wealth or just hit our live events
tab at ramseysolutions.com and you can
sign up doesn't cost anything but you do
have to sign up ahead of time
to be ready for the event this coming
thursday night cory is in little rock hi
corey welcome to the ramsey show what's
up
hi gabe how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
my name is corey
um i'm 32
and i
my boss just passed away a couple weeks
ago
and so he left me
some money
and so i'm just trying to really figure
out what i'm supposed to do like my dad
has told me what i need to do but it's
just it's a lot going on and i'm just
trying to because i don't have a job now
since my boss passed away but
boss left you money in his will
yes
wow that's an unusual arrangement
i was his personal assistant for eight
years
okay
yeah so he he did um
he was an oil contractor
and so i did all his
scheduling everything i was
as he used to call me his go-to
go-to gal
all the time so i mean i just kept up
with all his books and everything that
he needed done
his wife is the one that actually
called me and let me know that i was
left something oh okay so he didn't
leave everything to you no no no no no
no no
it's just an unusual story it's a
wonderful story but i'm trying to
understand so the uh how much did he
leave you
1.25
million dollars
yes
wow
oh my god
i couldn't vote i couldn't believe well
yeah well i mean was the old guy worth a
billion or something
he
he he has a lot i mean several
properties i've
helped him
manage his properties
he would take me on trips with him and
his family my kids he took care of my
kids i mean wow he was an amazing person
wow so are you married
no okay how old are you kiddos
i have a 15 year old a four-year-old a
three-year-old and 11
what was your income before before you
lost your job
i was making 65 okay 65 000 a year
1.25 million
wow and i was pretty much living
paycheck to patient doing that i mean i
shouldn't have but
i mean my kids are
i'm doing it on my own so yeah so do you
have any debt currently any consumer
yes i have um student loans i have about
forty thousand dollars in student loans
okay um we're renting an apartment so
just month by month that's twelve
hundred dollars for our rent
and then my car my mom gave me
um her car sorry i have a 2006 honda
odyssey
museum all right
well you're very wise you sound a little
bit overwhelmed by this a little bit
scared
[Music]
my dad suggested that i because my boss
was very flexible with my
went because he knew i had kids and
everything so it was a lot i could work
from home doing calls calls and
everything like that i could do a lot of
stuff from home
but
now
i don't think if i get another job i
will have it and it's kind of the
viewpoint my dad was looking at so he
was thinking like maybe if i take a
break until my youngest who's 11 month
old starts kindergarten
because right now it would be like
daycare for all of them well minus my 15
year old it would be daycare for all of
them and
he doesn't think that it would be wise
for me to go back to work just yet and
just
use the money
i don't i don't know okay all right well
what what i would suggest you do is that
you build a
um
let me kind of pan back let's just zoom
back for a second from worrying about
uh
what we're doing tomorrow
overall
someone just handed you 1.25 million
dollars to manage
that's your new job
and you don't know how to do it
okay is that right
yes that's why you call me
yeah and that doesn't make you bad it
doesn't make you bad it's just that
you've never managed 1.2 million dollars
before
right no
definitely not so what you do when you
have a a responsibility that large
which is what this is it's not a woohoo
i hit the lottery moment and i don't
hear that in your voice by the way
i hear a little bit of fear a little bit
of grief still from your friend passing
away a little bit of shock and awe which
i have in my voice that you got this
much money from your employer that's
pretty cool um
and uh so
here's what i suggest that people do
you need to a
number one
move
slowly
okay
if you feel urgency or someone pushing
you stop
okay
because where may people make mistakes
when they don't know what they're doing
is they go too fast let's pretend you're
driving a car for the very first time
i took my kid out in the church parking
lot with the jeep and the straight shift
to teach them how to do the strike drive
and to do the straight shift the first
rule is don't even change gears let's
just figure out and move
slowly get in trouble stop
right and that's what you're going to do
here because it's something you've never
done before
okay
second rule is the bible says in the
multitude of counsel there is safety
so i want you to build your own advisory
group your own board of directors
not to tell you what to do
but to advise you and teach you and then
you decide what to do
okay you got a pencil
yes you ready right
okay
first thing you need is you need an
investment advisor
click smart investor at
ramseysolutions.com you can find one
that we suggest
the second thing you need is a tax
advisor click tax elp ramsey
solutions.com and find one that you like
the third thing that you need
is sometime in the next year i suspect
you're probably going to buy a home and
pay cash for it an inexpensive home
under two hundred thousand dollars
okay and you're going to need a good
real estate agent
that's your third person on your board
on your advisory board again we've got
elps that can sit down with you and help
you with that
you need to make sure you have the right
kinds of insurance in place
so you need an insurance health
insurance anymore there you go you need
insurance in place and you again we've
got elps to help you with insurance
we're not in any of these businesses but
we've got people set up to where you can
form your advisory board and their goal
is not to tell you what to do and your
goal is not to hire a babysitter
you're a grown woman so your goal is to
gather information from advisors and by
which you go slow enough that you learn
and then you make the decisions
okay
and i think you can buy a home for cash
and invest some of this and not have to
go back to work
okay i can do like my dad said yep
but it's not it's not by using the money
it's by investing the money and using
the money that the investment creates
okay we're not going to use any of the
money
we're going to put it in an investment
and it throws off an income for you to
live on
okay with your investment advisor and
you're going to not need a lot of income
because your house is going to be paid
for and your car is going to be paid for
you're not going to have any debt and
you're going to be on a budget
okay because like i said i was
paycheck to paycheck you're not going to
live paycheck to paycheck anymore you're
just going to tell every dollar what
it's going to do that's coming in you're
going to have more dollars than you used
to have
okay and i want you to go through ramsey
plus go through financial peace
university and learn how to handle money
i'm going to pay for that we're going to
give it to you for a year
because you've got to get up on top of
this thing or you're going to live with
this horrible taste on the back of your
tongue called regret
move slowly and learn and put advisors
in your corner
hold on kelly will pick up and we'll
help
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print podcast on ramsey
networks is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
your money your work your relationships
and you we're here to help triple eight
eight two five five two two five justin
starts off this hour in miami hi justin
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave um
i need a quick education and potentially
some advice from you so i received a
call from someone from the lending arm
of the company that services my home
loan
and he was pitching me on the idea of
taking advantage of something called the
va earl program earl as an irrl
i don't know anything about this
and so my hesitancy is that hey it was a
cold call and that just makes me
skeptical in general but also i don't
know anything about the program orderly
speaking so my question to you is is the
va earl program as easy and risk-free as
i'm being led to believe or are there
some
traps out there that i need to avoid
you currently have a va loan correct
your current interest rate is what
4.25
and they're offering you the early what
earl at 2.75
and no closing costs
correct no appraisal no no closing cost
um he said there would be a two percent
increase in uh fees that should be paid
out within the first um
two to three years of the loan
and those fees would be routine costs
such as the va funding fee which would
be waived customer service connects
disability origination fees title
expenses
um things of that nature those are
closing costs
okay well then there are closing costs
he told me no closing costs but then he
told me there would be those fees so
yeah i don't know
those things are the definition of
closing costs
okay okay so um
i mean all they're talking all they're
talking about is they don't have to fool
with an appraisal because they've
already got the loan on the property and
they're just going to drop the thing in
there they're going to hit you with an
additional funding fee and the funding
fee was two percent no the whole thing
was two percent how much are they
hitting you with the funding fee one
percent
i'm not sure what that would be but it
would be way for me because i have oh
that's true your way have you got the
disability okay
um i i personally am not familiar with
the i'm familiar with the concept fha
has a concept that's very similar as
well
it's typically with fha it is slightly
above market interest rate and there's
no closing costs
with the va it sounds like they're just
hitting you with the funding fee and
you're paying it back over
in addition to your interest rate
correct
that's what that's my interpretation but
i'm not the expert so i was i was really
unsure i could i guess drill down on
those details yeah you need to get the
details out of it because the the
otherwise it sounds like it's a fairly
normal transaction the only thing i'm
worried about is how they're going to
tag you with those fees again you're not
getting hit with the funding fee because
of your disability and that is the
downside of a va loan for the rest of
you out there va loans are one of the
more expensive loans between fha va and
conventional va is the most expensive
which is odd it's supposed to be a
benefit to someone who served their
country but it's actually not because of
the funding fee if however you're
disabled then guess what the funding fee
is waived and now the va starts to be a
very reasonable loan at that point uh
the com the interest rates are slightly
higher but this 275 is fine in this
current market there's nothing wrong
with that rate
all things being equal if it's just as
cut and dry as this from 4.25 to 2.75
and all there is is the closing cost
uh you would say that it's a it's a done
deal pretty
okay yeah okay let's just let's pretend
your worst case scenario is the actual
closing costs what were the other cl
what were the other calls he was hitting
you with
uh the origination fee and title
expenses and he mentioned one or two
other things i didn't have an
opportunity to make note of
okay well this is a pretty standard va
loan
um
yeah
and if you pay those upfront i need to
know what this origination fee is
because if he's if he's jacked that's a
two percent this starts to not be as
good a deal
but basically the way you can do the
analysis when you get a hold of it is
you just do a break even analysis you
say all right you're going to say you're
going to go from four seven five you say
four two five or four seven five
it's four two five okay so you're going
to go
down
uh one and a half points yeah and your
interest rate on your current balance is
what
uh 172 000. okay so one percent 1700
bucks
one and a half is going to be 250. okay
no i missed that but it's going to be in
the 2 500 i'm sorry right in that range
all right so you're saving 2 500 a year
in interest by doing this if it costs
you 2500 out of your pocket it takes you
a year to break even
i'm talking
that's how you do the analysis on any
refinance and this sounds like a fairly
standard refinance i'm admitting to you
i don't know those initials but
everything else here sounds like a
standard va refinance to me
okay
yeah the initial acronym is interest
rate reduction refinance loan i've been
reading about it on
the va.gov website but i just i i'm not
familiar with it so i wanted to try and
pick your brain a little bit well they
dropped they dropped these types of
again fha has a very similar program and
they drop these things into an acronym
and it all comes down to a they've
already got the loan on the books b they
don't need to run an appraisal
and c they've got you as a customer and
they know they're going to lose you as a
customer because you can go get a 275 in
the open market and dump them in the
street so they want to try to retain a
customer that's where these things all
fall into that heading so there's
nothing here there's nothing weird here
going on it's a fairly standard product
that you're describing so very
interesting yeah well with the break
even analysis do you have parameters
where you say all right if i'm going to
break even within a year we're gonna go
ahead and do this yeah well assuming
you're gonna stay in the house all right
let's say i'm gonna i plan to stay in
the house next ten years okay
then how long how far out would you go
okay my closing costs are five thousand
bucks and i save 2 500 a year well
that's a two year break even
my closing costs are seven thousand five
hundred that's a three year
break even you could roll the closing
costs back onto the loan but you're
still breaking even after three years
um
much past that i start to worry about it
yeah three years of max two years used
to be our rule of thumb back in the day
in the real estate business if you can
break even in two years on your
refinance you ought to automatically do
it assuming you're staying home yeah
because but after that it starts to be a
lot of unknowns
the numbers are that the average home
loan pays off every 5.6 years
due to sale or refinance because the
average house sells every 6.8 years
used to be now with the current
weirdness who the crap knows but um but
that prior pre-covered those were the
numbers and so you know you don't want
to go out that far for your break even
so for me three starts to be
uncomfortable too it's kind of a slam
dunk one's definitely a slam dunk yeah
and same thing on the percentage point
if you save a percent or more do you go
all right that we gotta look at the
break even on this now but if you're
saving a quarter it's a quarter percent
doesn't matter it's how quick i can
break even
if a quarter percent allows me to break
even in six months i could do it it's a
lot of trouble first quarter percent a
lot of paperwork but uh usually you know
you're usually not gonna break even fast
enough unless you're saving one percent
or more to screw with it yeah but i've
seen a few cases where it's a little
less than one and still makes sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
happy new year
it's resolution season and if you're
like most people you make resolutions on
new year's day and give up on them by
valentine's day
have you ever noticed the gym is empty
by valentine's day that's so there's an
irony there just think about it why one
big reason is that you'd end up
making things happen all on your own
so you've decided if you decide to take
control of your money let me help you
you're gonna give up
if you don't get some people in your
corner and a process is proven
and that's called financial peace
university you get into a class you get
into an online class and you get with
some of our coaches and you get some
accountability and encouragement going
you won't quit
but most people quit otherwise
you get the proven plan in person and
online
your choice whatever mix you want to do
with financial peace university
it's of course part of ramsey plus and
that's how you get to it
you can get a free trial of financial
peace university and the every dollar
app
all built in together
no reason to uh wing it on your new
year's resolution to get out of debt
it's a free trial
let's go do this together we've been
doing it with millions of people for
decades ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
get a free trial for financial peace
university ramsey solutions dot com
slash fpu our question of the day comes
from blinds.com
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal rules and
restrictions apply today's question
comes from dennis in washington my
friend and i started a paint contracting
business this year we've already earned
1.4 million dollars with 500 000 as net
profit
we're worried about tax season because
we've never experienced financial
success like this before our accountant
recently told us we need to make some
expensive business purchases as
write-offs and my partner wants to buy a
truck for cash i really don't want to
spend thousands of dollars for potential
small tax savings what is the real wise
thing to do fire your accountant
right now it's an idiot
i'm serious accountants that can't do
math should not be employed
this is this just pisses me off they're
saying spend a bunch of money to save a
little bit of money well let me explain
to you how this works okay if you go buy
a truck
you do not get to write the truck off
and save the cost of the truck in taxes
let's say you have a
50 000 tax bill so you go buy a 50 000
truck
it does not work that way honey
you're counting some [ __ ] all right so
what happens when you buy a 50 000 truck
is you get to depreciate that truck over
three or five years depending on what
type of schedule you put it on
and as you'd appreciate it let's just
say we put it over five years for the
maths easy on my 50 000 that's ten
thousand dollars a year oh by the way
you don't get ten thousand dollars off
your taxes either
you get ten thousand dollars off of your
taxable income and so if you're in a
thirty percent bracket it saves you
three thousand dollars this year
to buy a fifty thousand dollar truck
your accountant is a [ __ ]
that math doesn't add up
you don't need to be trade fifty
thousand for three thousand you're a
[ __ ] okay that's just straight up
that's just an idiot now here's the
thing if you go buy business equipment
that you actually use in the business or
most of it is going to be on a
depreciation schedule of some kind under
some cases you can write the whole thing
off in one year
maybe it will
depending on what biden has done with
the trump tax stuff you may be able to
write it all off in one year but it's
even then ten thousand dollar write-off
for a ten thousand dollar expense saves
you three thousand dollars on your taxes
no you don't need to go spend money
to save on taxes
you're just going to pay some taxes
honey you became very successful i'm
sorry it sounds like they should have
just been putting that money aside
knowing i'm guessing they haven't been
doing quarterly estimates yeah this is
their accountant as a [ __ ]
this all happened to this year so that
this is all new to them but you know
taxes aren't new they've paid taxes
since they've been working so yeah
they've got to find a new tax if your
partner wants to go buy a truck for cash
you should do that with the money that
he takes out of the business as his
share
of the profits
and get ready to pay taxes on it
do not buy things for your business to
save on taxes only buy things for your
business that causes your business to
become more prosperous
now if you have some legitimate things
you can invest in that cause you make
even more money in business let's always
invest in those but we didn't do that
for tax reasons we did that because
we're going to make more money on the
item we purchased than the item cost
that's called a return on investment and
that's what you do in business you don't
put money in anything else but there is
no situation in tax where if you spend a
dollar you save a dollar no if you spend
a dollar you save maybe a quarter
maybe three cents
possible exception would be if you spend
some money on a new accountant who can
do math
and that might be a good return
off that's the question have i been
unclear about accountants who can't do
math any of you cpas and accountants who
tell people to go run up their expenses
in a business in order to save on taxes
ought to have your butt kicked up around
your neck
it's ridiculous when you people running
businesses start doing stuff just for
taxes you about to be out of business
when the lawyers and the bean counters
run your business you are screwed
you have to make decisions that are
business decisions i'm guessing these
are the same people that buy things on
their credit card on their business card
to get the rewards it's the same
mentality of i'm going to spend 10 grand
to get
200 my favorite one was my friend who's
an electrician the irony of this just
can never has been able to escape me
his idiot accountant told him that it
was okay for him to buy a houseboat
and write it off as a business expense
now there's no irony here that we're
talking about a boat with electricity
right electrician with a houseboat but
but i'm trying to explain to him junior
it's not a business expense that's not
his name his name's not junior but um
i'm like good lord bubba i mean you
understand he said well i'm going to
have like business parties on it i will
i will entertain customers how many days
a year two days a year okay you can you
can actually depreciate to
365th
of this houseboat
and you can write off the booze that you
bought for the party and that's it bubba
that's it your accountant is a [ __ ] oh
my god this is so freaking stupid yeah
the fraction on that hurts my brain it's
so little it's yeah yeah and it's just
and and it's an electrician buying a
boat with water and electricity on it
that just that is always it's just
bothering me but yeah
uh yeah but the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh this is something we get with entree
leadership all the time
business people who are smarter than
their accountants smarter than their
lawyers start taking orders
from people that are dumber than them
no no go go to ramseysolutions.com click
on elp for taxes get you a new tax
person that can add
can y'all tell can you tell it bothers
me a little bit a little riled up there
dave i'm not going to lie bothers me a
little bit but i like the fire today
it's um
well business stuff especially riles you
up you've been in this business long
enough 30 years and i've been helping
small businesses with entre leadership
we've been tens of thousands of them for
decades and i just love small business
people and this young guy man they went
out and they kicked butt
they are absolutely killing it man i
mean they're wearing it out a million
dollars in that revenue in the first
year half a million in pain contracting
that's a lot of pain profit
and what happens to a wonderful young
guy like this
yeah
yeah just out of control man it's
absolutely out of control you just can't
live that way
so um no i uh
you you make
all
business decisions on economic values
not on tax law
whatever tax law happens happens now you
can do a few things here or there on
taxes you may want to
push some expenses into december too
late now
if you're on a cash basis accounting
system so that you can get the write-off
in last year
looks like biden's gonna change capital
gains so would have been a good idea to
dump some capital gains stuff last year
you can do some tax planning around some
things
and you should do that you should be
wise about this but this idea that we're
gonna run up expenses in business to
save on taxes
just exhausting you done riled them up
dennis you done riled them up this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here on the
ramsey show it's a free call some say
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it triple eight eight two five five
two two five in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage kyle
and jessica are with us hey guys how are
you great great welcome where do you
guys live austin texas austin very cool
how much debt have you paid off 175 000.
how long did this take it took us three
years in one month three years and one
month and your range of income during
that time uh we started at 72 000 and
right now i'm making about 160 000.
that's a nice job yes
like what what happened to the income i
gotta ask um just different job
opportunities and saying yes like
somebody wasn't working now somebody is
no no no both of you just went way up
i'm a stay-at-home mom for our two kids
about to be three um and he just got
some great job opportunities what do you
do for a living i'm a software engineer
oh okay i got it okay yeah all right
wait a couple good one definitely that's
amazing what's the kind of debt was this
175 000 um 25 000 was car loans and the
rest was student loans whoa
150 000 student loans what's your degree
in computer science at least this one's
paying off huh yes yeah you're making
some good bank with it and uh pretty
quick how old are you guys
26. how long have you been married we
are coming up on five years in a couple
weeks okay wow so a couple years into
marriage
you're making 70 grand you got 175
000 monkey on your back
ouch this doesn't sound fun
you're 24 years old at that point right
oh my gosh this doesn't sound this
sounds like it was awful yes it was a
lot we um
whenever he graduated from school it was
all student loans on his end and so we
sat down and looked at the numbers and
we were really intimidated um
but we'd heard about your program before
and we sat down and looked at it and we
just it made the most sense and so we
decided to start um it didn't start
right away because we were making so
little whenever um he was finishing up
school and i was working um but around a
year and a half into marriage whenever
our daughter was born we started paying
off and then three years later here we
are i love it wow
well one thing about a software engineer
when they see a system they work it yes
you know that's it man it's like you're
a process guy you saw the process ding
ding right that was it yeah wow what
were your payments do you remember all
the debt added up what were those
payments every month oh my gosh um
she still feels it i can tell her yes
um i'm trying to think it was minimums
were about 2 000 a month but we always
paid extra
for the most part on those so at least 2
000 but we usually paid quite a bit more
we're two thousand dollars a month
richer yeah oh it's amazing it's like
it's quite unbelievable oh the i mean we
feel it every single day i don't think
we've forgotten about it since we paid
it off i mean it just
you can feel the weight off of your
shoulders yeah you physically can feel
that oh yes every day oh my gosh and you
guys are 26 i mean you must have a lot
of friends probably other software
engineers who are sitting there with
another 150 in loans going well i'm just
going to pay this off until i die that's
the only way yeah yeah we figured we
were already pretty broke college
students and so it wasn't really a big
jump going to
because we even though we were making
more once we graduated we just pretended
like we were still those broke college
students um so all that extra money that
we were making we just put towards the
loans and kind of forgot like we had um
so we just lived as frugally as we could
in the meantime wow
wow
okay so people find out you paid off a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars that's impressive y'all are
studs it's amazing this is you guys are
power couple man this is so cool so
proud of you thank you when they find
out you did this they say how'd you do
that what do you tell them
well one thing that was helpful for me
was just having that vision of what you
want life to be like in the future and
just
every sacrifice and everything you have
to do to make that happen if you hold
that vision it helps it be more real and
i think just being a team because we are
always on the same page from the
beginning and that made it go so much
quicker
and just realizing that we could still
have a great life in the meantime we
could still have fun together
we just found a lot of free activities
like we would go hiking with our kids
all the time and things that didn't cost
extra money
and we just learned to live and enjoy
life in the moment so we learned to make
it fun even when it was really hard yeah
it was three years is a long time but in
the scope of your life it ain't spit
exactly you know you live like no one
else you got the rest of your life
to live and give like no one else and
man you are you're you got you got a
great career choice so you'll be able to
make good money and you you know you
control a lot of your own destiny here
you guys are really this is this is
impressive thank you this is impressive
if you guys accomplished this in three
years i'm like what are you gonna
accomplish in the next 30 i'm i'm scared
you guys are gonna do so unbelievably
well we can't wait we're excited as well
we've been dreaming big so yeah what's
the next big thing
um buying a house yeah yeah yeah take
some trips and buy a save with that down
payment up and get a house now very good
very good how many kids you got we have
uh two daughters and then we're pregnant
with our boy right now
[Applause]
that's the ramsey that's the ramsay
lineup two daughters followed by a boy
yeah that's excited very good we ought
to be it's great good times good times
well congratulations you guys we're
proud of you here thank you you're the
kind of people that we love helping and
uh you're very impressive thank you very
impressive your heroes you took control
of your life and uh just beautifully
beautifully done gives me hope for this
generation dave you know it turns out
they're not all bad oh we knew that we
knew that here that we see it all the
time yeah very cool
very cool all right we've got a copy of
the baby steps millionaire book that
comes out next week an advanced copy
and uh because that's the next chapter
in your story you'll be there before you
know it at this rate bing ding man
you're just zooming right on zooming
right along very well done and a copy
total money makeover as well so you can
give that to somebody disturb their life
help them get on the same track teach
them the system you used because they're
going to ask
they're going to ask because you start
to walk different and smile different
when you don't have almost 200 000 worth
of monkey on your back definitely pretty
stinking incredible you guys are amazing
very very well done
kyle and jessica austin texas
175 thousand dollars paid off three
years in one month making 72 all the way
to 160 during that three years nice jump
count it down let's hear a debt free
screen all right three three two one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's done boys and girls oh
my goodness the future's looking bright
for that that couple yeah well here's
the thing
we see continuously in all of the
millionaire data from baby steps
millionaire and from the ramsey research
on millionaires
all the data that we've got that people
who have a tenant who are in industries
that are process oriented have have been
a chance they have the best chances so
the number one
the most likely career field to become a
millionaire
in all the millionaires we've studied is
engineer software engineer here right
okay the engineers are process driven
one plus one equals two we don't have to
have an existential argument about it by
god one plus one equals two
accountants number two
teachers
number three and if you don't anything
about putting together a lesson plan or
running a classroom full of
animals
that's called teaching
then you know they are process driven
people
number three
uh managers and entrepreneurs
number four lawyers if you've ever dealt
with lawyers they're process driven
human beings the number five the five
top career fields or people who end up
being millionaires are all process
driven now that's not to say that if
you're an artist you don't have a shot
you have a shot but you need to
understand that there's a correlation
between being following a freaking
process and becoming wealthy that's why
we wrote the baby steps millionaire it's
a process to become wealthy and you have
to submit yourself to a process
not try to be
an artist with it it's it's science it
ain't art yeah that's a great way to put
it and you're right there's this level
of you can't just wish for it you can't
just hope for it you have to put the
behaviors in in play to make it happen
but you know those of us that have a
creativity binge you and me included
yeah i've got i'm a process guy but i've
also got a creativity binge meaning that
i always question everything right i
have to go well i don't care about your
baby steps i want to make my own you
know i'm the same [ __ ] out there that
some of you are that are listening right
now don't go make your own it's painful
you know follow the plan you know what
that guy did he never even questioned it
follow him
he just did it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personalities my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
max is in corpus christi hi max welcome
to the ramsey show
howdy dave thanks for taking my call
sure man what's up um so i'm a
midshipman uh second year midshipman at
the united states naval academy
and i'm just kind of trying to figure
out how i want to set up my
outlook going forward so i'm going to
graduate here in two and a half years
with no debt um or i have the option of
doing that or i can take what's called
the career starter loan no from usa or
well it's a 0.75 percent interest loan
okay because the idea was to cover your
car and home started but you're not
covering your car you're borrowing money
for a car
fair enough that's what my
brother-in-law said you'd say that was
easy hold on so you said the other
option was graduate debt-free
yeah yeah or you can go 50 grand in debt
right
oh 32. yeah what's wrong with that
somebody ought to smack those people for
doing that to you guys you guys are
serving your country thank you so much
for who you are young man thank you
please don't go falling into a ditch
okay because it was
because all the financial investors are
like well most people that do it beat
the interest within a year in the stock
market
hey let me okay let me tell you what
they are they're full of crap
okay and let me tell you why i know that
i'm not just making this up
we studied
max 10
000
millionaires
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america
do you know how many of them
told us
that they borrowed money
at one percent interest
and invested it in the market and that
caused them to be millionaires
precisely zero
zero
zero
none of them
very well and they weren't trying to get
a commission
off of a young midshipman
to get him to borrow money at the
freaking credit union to put it into his
mutual fund
you need to run from those financial
people because they haven't got your
best interest at heart you are sharp
young guy you're getting ready to go i
assume you're going to be an officer
correct
yes sir you're in the navy of the marine
corps i'm hoping to fly for the marine
corps yeah oh you're gonna fly oh even
better wow good for you
man that's amazing
and so your your future in an aircraft
military or non-military later is bright
your income is bright everything is
there don't saddle yourself
with these kinds of problems all in an
effort to accelerate your wealth
building process because there's no data
points to back it up
that makes sense
okay man i just i appreciate who you are
and i really don't want you to do this i
hope you hear me loud and clear i'm not
i'm not just being a smart aleck with
you i am being a smart aleck with the
morons around you though oh my gosh
who's selling him on the benefit of 32
000 in debt is not looking out for him
so let me let me just kind of walk this
through george for a second it's
important
because it sounds like we don't know how
to do math to people like those people
that are advising him so for you morons
out there that are teaching you some
young guy stuff like this here's where
you're wrong
okay
at 32 dollars and he can borrow the
money at one percent or so
if he invested in mutual funds and he
made ten or twelve percent does he not
make the spread
yes he does maybe he does make the
spread
however what you need to understand is
that your formula that you have used is
a
naive and incomplete
b
short-sighted let me explain
naive and incomplete means you have not
factored in risk
let me show you how i know you've not
factored in risk
it didn't bother anyone that this young
guy is going to borrow 32 000 at one
percent
so let's just put some x's on it
if 32 000 at one percent makes him
profit
if he could do 3.2 million at one
percent should he
now
what's the difference
it's a bigger number the bigger number
makes your heart
measure the risk you feel it some of you
just got tight in the chest or your
stomach raised up just a little bit even
when i suggested that the young man be
3.2 million dollars in debt
but if the math works at 32 000 why
wouldn't the math work at 3.2 because at
3.2 you finally physically it felt in
your chest the risk
but you didn't feel it before so you
thought you were some kind of
ba
with your math you left out risk
you left out risk
risk is math
and you have to insert risk in the
process
and otherwise you get your freaking head
taken off and so
just because the risk feels small
doesn't mean it's not there
and doesn't mean it's that you so your
your your
formula 1 versus 10 or 12 percent spread
is incomplete because you left out risk
number two
it's naive because you didn't take into
consideration the fact that you have a
young man getting into the
cockpit of a fighter jet
some of the most sophisticated equipment
on the planet
where you can kill someone over the
horizon
and never see them or be killed by
someone over the horizon and never see
them uh it is a bizarre
set of technology
it the world's best in humankind history
and you have a young guy in his early
20s getting ready to climb into that
cockpit oh and let's go ahead and put in
the back of his mind that he has thirty
two thousand dollars worth of debt
and act like that doesn't matter
of course it matters
the number three cause of dishonorable
discharge in the military is financial
irresponsibility
they lose their security clearance and
they lose their battle readiness because
they're preoccupied with crap in the
back of their mind because some [ __ ]
financial advisor suggested there was a
spread between 1 and 10.
there's more to this stuff folks than
meets the eye that's my point yeah and
you also have to wonder how much
payments beget payments where he goes
all right well i've already got the
sturge 2000 why not go get a car loan
uh and why not go get payments over here
and payments over here and run up a
credit card and it just begins
normalizing it normalizes it exactly and
i got to tell you man these guys preying
on the military people it pisses me off
you leave a military base
and you you know if you go to a military
town you leave the military you leave
the gates of the base
as soon as you leave the gates of the
base there is stupid on each side of the
road for about two miles
every dumb human trick you can do is on
one side of the road or the other for
about two miles they are set up like a
bunch of freaking piranha
to feed on these guys from payday
lenders
to uh whoever else out there
and this is a innocuous kind of a loan
he's talking about there's nothing to
this loan but i mean the the horrible
financial products
horrible deals on cars
horrible
behaviors they can engage in
none of which are good for them none of
which are good for their battle
readiness none of which are good for
their military career and it's just it's
it's it's sad
that that that these people are preying
on the very people who are young people
are not making a lot of money in most
cases and they're here to serve us yeah
what do you think makes them more
vulnerable
to these kinds of decisions well it's
the same you know it's the same age as a
college student who went and got you
know
got a degree in beer pong
you know you got stupid outside the
college as soon as you walk off the
college campus for two miles you got
stupid on each side of the road too it's
the same thing they're preying on the
young
that are inexperienced at life and think
that i want to try all these new things
that look like fun and will bring death
death to your finances death to your
relationships death to your
future relationships uh i mean it it's
it's a problem man it's a problem
and so i'm not suggesting legislation to
protect it but i am suggesting that that
you know the military really ought to do
some orientation just like a college
should do an orientation it's not just
about what's happening on the campus
it's about what's happening just off the
campus that'll kill your butt and mess
you up and set you on a trajectory that
takes you 10 years to recover from and
you know you're turning a guy 18 gal 18
years old loose with their first
paycheck unsupervised and
and and the first thing you do is drop
them in a pool of piranha
and it's just oh my god man that pisses
me off can you tell i can tell
i mean we just love the military and
we've worked with them for so many years
with financial heart for financial peace
university and they're they're
the vast majority of them are young
very young and are susceptible to this
kind of thing and it's harsh it's really
harsh
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsey show where we talk about your
life your money your work
your relationships george camel ramsey
personality is my co-host today
he and i will be helping you if you want
the help with any of those areas you
jump in the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five
two two five
sierra starts us off this hour in tacoma
washington hi sierra how are you
better than i deserve how about yourself
just the same how can we help
well i've got a question so my boyfriend
is having a lot of money troubles and
his family is going for bankruptcy right
now
and i'm wondering how i can help
[Music]
does he live at home
yes okay he's 17. 17 years old
and uh obviously you guys are just
dating and so i don't want you to help
them financially are you saying more
emotionally how do you help right now
i don't know i just i want to do
something
well they're already through they're
going through the bankruptcy process as
we speak
yeah
how old are you sierra
16
okay
all right
um
yeah the only way you can actually help
in this situation with both of you being
minors and not being married
is
just uh love and support emotional
support there's it's not your
responsibility or your place and it
would be inappropriate for you to put
money into this scenario
so
you would just
care about him care about his mom and
dad they're scared
he's scared there's a lot of uncertainty
around this even if they're acting like
they're not scared i've been through
bankruptcy it's scary
and um
so you can just support him uh let me
kind of give you a metaphor to think
about all right
how would you help him
if his mom
was going through chemo with cancer
uh
i i just
i'd be there for him exactly
you really can't help his mom
the doctors have to do that
whether she makes it or not is not up to
you
it's up to god and the doctors in my
metaphor that i just made up here my
storyline that i just made up
uh obviously that's not happening at
least i hope it's not um
it'd be a horrible choice of metaphors
if it was but the uh um but but you know
the yeah so i think it's something
similar the difference with the money
thing is it feels like there's something
we're supposed to do to like buy food or
something like that and that's not
necessary in bankruptcy
uh if the are his mom and dad working do
they have jobs
yes okay then they have money for food
even in bankruptcy
yeah okay and they have money for lights
and water
and depending on the type of bankruptcy
and what's going on with the house
there's a strong possibility they'll be
staying in the house
yeah
so we got food shelter clothing
transportation utilities
so the basic necessities of life are
there but it's just um they've they've
obviously made some mistakes
with their money and and now they're
having it they've got you know they've
got a lot of pain because of it and so
if you can just do that if treated like
his mom's got cancer what would you do
you just be there for him emotionally
because he can't fix his parents
situation and neither can you
yeah and he's actually having a hard
time too because
his vehicle is not working and he's
trying to get it fixed
so he can come to work
okay
and uh what does he what does he do when
he's at work
um
he actually works my dad
he does we do farm work okay good
okay
uh what's wrong with this car
um
let's see something in the transmission
broke but it's right in the middle the
transit transmission so
you have to take it all apart to try to
fix what it is
any of the guys on the farm able to help
with that
um well it's just me and my dad and
my sister and my mom we don't really
know how to
do cars a whole lot okay is his income
intact still
your boyfriend
what does he make when he works at the
farm
uh
let's see works two days a week so you
get to 5000 a month
okay is he in school right now
yes okay
well we're both homeschooled so
oh okay all right that's good news all
right well i think he's probably going
to scrape together a little bit of money
and if your dad as his employer
wants to help him out a little bit with
getting his transmission fixed and let
him work that off that wouldn't be a bad
thing i would do that possibly for one
of my employees here
or i might even give them a gift to help
them get through a rough patch with the
by buying them a used transmission or
something like that i've done that kind
of thing as an employer i don't know if
your dad's in a position to do that
you're not you're 16 you don't give him
money period
okay
if that's my opinion and you asked okay
and i i think you've got a big heart and
i think you are mature beyond your years
um
you carried yourself well on a radio
show here calling in uh with millions of
people listening at 16 years old you're
an impressive young woman yeah and on on
top of that sierra it sounds like he
needs encouragement right now because he
feels like his parents mistakes are his
mistakes and that their lives are going
to become his life and so the best thing
you can do is remind him that it doesn't
have to be that way and as you guys
progress in your relationship if this is
a long-term thing or you guys end up
getting married you can change that
cycle you can change that family tree it
is possible and the fact that you're
calling in gives me a lot of hope that
you you have a heart to want to change
this so you're doing great uh be there
for him but know that you can't change
their situation yeah and if you guys if
your dad again wants to step in and help
him with getting the car fixed or
getting a beater car or got an old
pickup on the farm that you can get
started and let him drive it until he
can get his car fixed or some way like
that to him give him a little direct
help on the car situation only
that's fine but that's your dad's call
it's not requirement it would be an act
of generosity on your dad an optional
act on your dad's part but your george
is exactly right i think you remind him
that um
you know everyone has every one of us
that have parented
or that have parents
and most of us have parents
uh uh have the idea that we can make
better decisions than they did in the
next time the next generation and that
thank goodness is true thank goodness
you have the option of making better
decisions than your parents did and
that's a universal human thing that we
all all have that ability so i think
you're going to be great i appreciate
your heart and appreciate you checking
in it's a powerful why a lot of the
people on the debt-free stage some of
their wives were i wanted to do things
differently than how i was raised yep
absolutely well done well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's
slash ken betheltech.net
[Music]
[Music]
it's happening in one week
you have six days left to get the deal
[Music]
in one week the baby steps millionaire
book will be shipped to your house
your bookstores you will begin to see it
on the shelves
and we are so excited about this book
it's the first book i've done in eight
years the last one i did i did with my
daughter rachel cruz smart money smart
kids was a number one
best-selling book
and so we're excited to show you how to
become a millionaire using the baby
steps
without any question the proof is in the
book we're going to prove it to you with
math we're going to prove it to you with
experience we're going to prove it to
you with research we're going to prove
it to you that you can do this
and that you should do this
and we're going to walk you through it
the baby steps millionaire book
see i lost everything it had to start
completely over
and i i'm so dumb i had to do it twice
so i know you can be a millionaire
and it's it's an important thing to have
a goal with your finances so if you want
to pre-order your copy of baby steps
millionaires today at
ramseysolutions.com you can do that it's
only twenty dollars if you pre-order it
and you get over a hundred dollars worth
of items added to it
uh we the baby steps millionaires
audiobook and ebook the legacy journey
audio book and ebook will be sent to you
immediately the ramsey smart tax
filing for your federal taxes
is completely free and included and a
30-day free trial to ramsey plus which
is you know sets you up for
uh financial peace university it sets
you up for
every dollar the app to show you exactly
how to become a baby steps millionaire
and george and rachel and i will be
doing a free live stream
next thursday a week from this thursday
january the 13th
called building wealth in 2022. yeah i'm
really excited about this and you're
gonna you know it's this is not just a
pitch for the book you're really going
to show people and talk about trending
topics like nfts and crypto and nothing
down real estate and inflation these are
the things that are on people's minds
right now and so we want to address it
head on and say hey we know this is
what's going on but here's how you can
actually build wealth the right way and
not listen to your broke brother-in-law
tell you about how you need to put all
your money in crypto yeah yeah and
believe me it's out there and so you
know we're gonna help you it's not just
about trashing something it's about
showing you
step by step a proven plan
of how to win
it's how ordinary people became
millionaires and how you can too it's
that simple how you can become wealthy
and and not become wealthy so that
you're a wealthy jerk become wealthy so
you have options in your life so you
have dignity so you can retire with
dignity so you can change your family
tree so you can help others with
outrageous generosity these are the
reasons to build wealth
john's with us in sacramento hey john
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and george i appreciate you
guys taking my call sure i'll start off
with my
general question which is i have a 45
000 bonus i'll be getting this month and
i'm trying to figure out if i should put
it towards our mortgage completely or
divide it up into putting into some
mutual funds in addition
um the general information about us
since my wife and i are 34 years old we
have one child and one on the way yay
yeah yeah very exciting boy and a girl
um
and our take home after taxes and
putting 15 percent into retirement um
after both of those is 8 500 a month
and we have a hundred thousand in the
bank uh 70 000 in our retirement
accounts and we're debt free except for
our house
and so i'm just trying to gain plan um
we have 200 000 left to pay off on our
house and we have a plan that we want to
implement
to pay off our house in the next six
years by the time we're 40 uh which we
can do
um but trying to figure out if how big
is your bonus that we're
45 000.
and you got 100 000 in the bank and you
make what you mean you make eighty-five
should you make 140 000 a year
uh yes okay
so
let me get this straight what's the 100k
doing in the bank
um we were stockpiling money for a long
time until we pivoted to recently to
trying to put a bunch more money into
our retirement instead
okay
well you've got 200 mortgages
yeah you've got no debt right except the
house
and you've got 145 000 do you have any
um do you have any money other than the
hundred thousand like for an emergency
fund
uh the hundred thousand would
i
but we we also have 75 000 in retirement
accounts yeah so what do you think your
emergency fund should be
uh for six months um assuming that we
live slimly for that time if we needed
it it would be about thirty thousand
dollars
okay so you got 70 left plus the 45 so
you're looking at 115 you could use
towards this house
yeah leaving you with 85k on the
mortgage so you're debt-free in two
years not six years
sure i'm excited thinking about it i
hadn't thought about it that way i i i
admittedly i think my wife and i like
stuffing a lot of money under the pillow
so to speak but that's a habit we're
currently trying to break which is part
of the reason why i'm calling it well
it's not a bad habit i'll just tell you
that um
the reason that you're doing that is the
security gland
you know and down in your belly is
telling you to i feel secure when i do
that and i will tell you someone who's
done both either put money under the
pillow or paid off my house uh that
paying off your house gives you much
more satisfaction for the security gland
than the pillow does
you you you know you know how you kind
of feel if you had 200 000 under the
pillow
sure if you'll 2x that feeling that's
the way it's going to feel when you pay
off your house
paying off your house is even more cool
for your security gland than your pillow
is that's what i'm saying yeah yeah for
sure you can't know that until you do it
but that's coming for you i can see that
in your future
and that's what i want for you so that
you can go become very wealthy now you
need to start putting 15 of your income
away into retirement steady as a part of
your 401k but that's a part of a budget
not a part of a lump sum thing
you said you're already doing that and
we started doing that yeah we started
doing that a couple years ago oh i miss
that i apologize i'm sorry
yeah let's put 120 130 000 or something
like that on this house and then let's
line up and knock off that other 70
grand
making
a hundred and forty uh i don't know
two years you're debt-free right
yeah and you've got meantime you're
sitting on 50 grand with no payments in
the world you make 140 your life's
pretty dead gum good man you're doing
well way to go oh and the baby's on the
way woohoo yeah life is great
yeah yeah
yeah not not too shabby that's for sure
i will tell you this if you pay off your
house
and you hate being debt-free you can go
get a mortgage they'll let you
yeah i i so i've heard from many
i think there's a little uh you can get
paralyzed with all the decisions well i
could do this and i could put it in
mutual funds and i could do this and
what i love about the baby steps is it
just filters everything and gives you
this clear view of how to approach money
and for me that's pay off the house
first and then you can invest yeah and
it's exactly right and he's got a great
question but and your point about the
baby steps is this it is the fastest
easiest
way to become a millionaire
which is the
underlying question not not
not that i need to be a millionaire okay
but the fastest easiest way to wealth
okay so that i can do all the things
that wealth will do like we're talking
about a minute ago but the fastest
easiest way is important if the fastest
easiest way was put some in mutual funds
i would do that
what's the fastest easiest surest
most proven way
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement
be funding your kids college fund baby
step five six is pay off your house as
soon as the house is paid off max out
all your retirement and you can save
like a crazy person and you've got all
kinds of cash flow and wiggle room in
your life
to do that's people that only have
enjoyment but also do incredible
investing yeah a lot of people don't
think about the fact that if you don't
have a house payment then you have all
of the cash flow and with all of that
you can invest all of it if you want to
and all of it's like all of it and then
you can be a millionaire times two or
three you know how fast you become a
millionaire without a house payment oh
my god the math is
it's the fastest
easiest
most sure way
to wealth to follow these baby steps
that's why we wrote baby steps
millionaire to go with the total money
makeover with financial peace it's it's
this path
that is very clear and very proven
and we get to talk about it every day
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage steven and casey are
with us hey guys how are you hi dave
doing great welcome where do you guys
live arlington texas all right welcome
to nashville and all the way here to do
a debt free screen how much have you
paid off uh 180 thousand dollars in
three years 11 months
love it love it love it what was your
range of income during that time uh
started out we were around 120 and then
we peaked a little over 170 and we
backed off a little bit we're down to
about 150 now excellent what do you guys
do for a living i'm a firefighter i am a
nurse but now staying home mostly with
our babies ah there's the back off a
little bit and you had the opportunity
to put the put some wood on the fire i'm
sure and work some ot lately no question
about that and that helped push this
through what kind of debt was the 180
uh well
this one was on me we had a home depot
credit card
uh student loans we paid off a vehicle
um new windows that we put on the house
and then we paid off uh
the house the house
looking at you guys well done
so fabulous congratulations
man that is neat neat neat i love it
well congratulations we're proud of you
very cool what started this journey
three months and 11 years ago
um we
by accident had a true zero dollar
budget at the end of the month we had no
money and i was always moving money back
and forth to cover the bills because the
bills and the paychecks never lined up
and so i figured that the obvious
problem was we weren't making enough
money
so i was bouncing around on youtube
trying to figure out how to make more
money i was looking at doing uh rental
homes and that just didn't sound right
and then i kind of sort of landed on
this weird bald guy on the internet who
was talking about paying off your debt
and i just started binge watching your
videos wow wow just like that okay
it had been slowly building for us
we just kept moving money and i was
always calling him and saying are we
okay if i go to the grocery store this
week do we need to wait and it was
literally paycheck to paycheck and i had
been out of nursing school i was working
more and more shifts yeah you've got
big-time careers you're making 100 000
bucks plus spending time away from our
babies and yet the math was not i'm like
okay we should be adding money not
taking money away and it's not adding up
and the moment that really got me was i
called him one day i said i need to go
to the store and buy groceries it was a
tuesday and he's like hold on a second
he did the math and he said no you're
going to have to wait till friday and
that just as a mom just really hit me
hard i'm like
i need to buy food for our babies it's
not okay it's not okay and and for me it
stemmed from a childhood where money was
always a stress in our house
and that really hit those security
buttons hard
and i was like i'm not gonna do this
with my children like something has to
change and he came home and he's like i
found this guy and i think we're going
to get out of debt and i said okay and
he goes
but i had a speech
i had the whole thing planned out
and literally walked in the door and
said we should pay off our debt she goes
let's do it okay
so you're ready to fight you're right
here's why i wanted to do this
he had a persuasive speech
laid out he'd been practicing it at the
fire hall absolutely i love it
wow and you were like no i'm ready we're
good let's go it was pretty much it was
a game on at that point we paid off the
home depot credit card that day
the teacher will appear yeah wow and we
binged watched youtube like there's no
tomorrow
and that was the only place you
connected to us we we got the book we
read the book and i mean literally
we would put the kids to bed every night
and we'd say you're ready to get your
ddd and we call it our daily dose of
dave and we would just i mean it was
like we couldn't get enough information
and we just learned from everybody else
and from what you said
and i mean it was just i mean we still
play the podcast in our kitchen when
we're cooking dinner and our 10 year old
walks by the other day and he goes
budget budget budget
that's a pretty good impression i said
that's right buddy
that's right man changed your little
family tree yeah
this food you're eating here buddy this
is because we've been doing this yeah i
like it well done guys
all right what advice have you got to
someone who's
right where you were it's
tuesday they want to buy groceries and
they look at the account and say we got
to wait on friday when the check comes
in
i've had it
what do they need to do what are the
things you guys did you say we did these
three things and it made all the
difference
well the first thing is is that being
humble and admitting that the way you've
been doing things is wrong
i think that's the toughest part people
don't like to admit they're wrong
and then
it might seem like the plan is so far
out like for us it was four years and
four years in the future seems like it's
forever away but four years in the past
seems like it was yesterday it really
isn't that long that's good oh that's a
good line yeah yeah
it does i mean that's that is true uh at
times go really really fast
um i mean i'm getting old it's like
decades feel like they just went by you
know because your grandbabies are
growing up now you're going oh my gosh
that's just passing well i look at that
house over there and i go i remember
that house on this kid wait a minute
that house is 50 years old that's
ridiculous you know that kind of stuff
it goes fast the past the past goes fast
uh and you're gonna live the four years
anyway you might as well do something
with exactly yeah so so the the keys are
that it's going to go it's not as hard
as it sounds it's going to go it's going
to go faster than you think it's going
to what's the other keys it's it's a
head game you know it's
there was nothing that anybody could
have said to either of us to make us
stop
because we both were in agreement and
that's all we needed was each other
nothing's gonna stop them well the
crazier thing for us is you know like
any couple we have our arguments we we
never really fought over money but you
know we'd have our fights and then when
we were on this program and we were just
hammering like fights like we didn't
fight about anything we were on board
with anything with the kids anything
with the house it just
it strengthened our marriage absolutely
absolutely well you got a common goal
and we said okay we're going to set this
aside for the common goal we're gonna
live like no one else so later we can
live and give like no one else and now
when people make fun of me for having
five kids i'm like yeah but we have a
paid for house and they're going to
college free so
you know house and everything she just
dropped the mic on all of them
yeah
gotta answer for that do you yeah come
at me bro how you like me now so what's
the house worth
uh 370.
way to go we're just we're
just shy he ran the numbers you want to
say oh yeah we did uh we did our net
worth before we came here and we're
we're almost baby step millions
all right
yeah we're right there we're giving you
a pass at 975
you didn't know but the stock market
went up today
so your mutual funds went up 25 000
today
i just declared it congratulations thank
you it's incredible
baby steps millionaires how old are you
i'm 43. i'm 38. and five kids five kids
wow and a dog and dog you can't do it
with a large family dave ramsey stuff
doesn't work with a large family shut up
they just took away america's excuses
right there you guys just you guys just
mike dropped on all of them man this is
so great well done thank you so how does
it feel
to be a millionaire at 40 years old
it's surreal
it's
there's no stress well
except for five kids there's no money
stress
right yeah
that kid that one yeah we've kind of
been so gazelle intense i told them it's
like that movie finding nemo when they
finally escaped from the fish tank and
they're all floating in the ocean in the
little bags they're like
now what
[Laughter]
it's a great analogy
now what do we do
in the ocean
so fun so fun well well done you guys
we're very proud of you we've got a copy
of baby steps millionaires to celebrate
that you hit that milestone as well uh
an advanced copy because the book
actually comes out next week and we'll
give you a copy you are truly the
epitome of a baby steps millionaire very
very well done
good good stuff
and uh we're proud of you heroes
excellent job copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and
disrupt someone else's world that's in
the middle of this and needs their world
disrupted that's what we're here for to
cause a holy ruckus that's our plan
around here so well done you guys are
amazing i'm honored to talk to you
stephen and casey fort worth texas 180
000 paid off in three years and eleven
months making 120 to 170 house and
everything and oh by the way baby steps
millionaires count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
oh
and you're driving along the road
listening to this wondering if you two
can do this
and the answer george
you can
simple as that pretty simple answer this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 15 16 you
did not choose me but i chose you and
appointed you so that you might go and
bear fruit fruit that will last and so
whatever you ask in my name
the father will give you
dale carnegie said develop success from
failures discouragement and failure are
two of the surest stepping stones
to
success
amen and amen
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today jonathan is in houston
texas hey jonathan welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you to the both of you it's a good
afternoon afternoon how can we help
yes sir so recently uh my wife and i
just got married back in december which
is great
and to give you some contacts that we
have
a uh we are both free we have it fully
from the emergency fund and we're
following the baby steps which is great
and we live with
my parents
so as you can see we are motivated by
home and we are wanting to stick within
the parameters that you provide being
the 15 and fixed and the fourth of our
take home and we are looking around but
we find ourselves not finding a home
that fits our needs so we've inquired
about a grant that's being offered here
in houston area and with me being an
employee of the national bank that comes
along with some perks but even with all
that stuff
we're still not finding ourselves with a
home that we thought really want to fall
in love with and make and make that big
purchase how old are you my question to
you is what should we do how old are you
i am
i am 26 and my wife is 25.
and what's your household income
uh gross is about 120.
okay
um
and how much do you have say for a down
payment
uh not much
again we have a fully funded emergency
fund i would say maybe after that i
would have
just under 10 grand possibly
so we wouldn't have enough for a 20 down
payment and maybe not even 10
and like i said we were looking at our
parents in the meantime
yeah i got you and you got and you just
got married the other day
uh december of last year yesterday 14th
yeah like two weeks ago yeah sometimes
yeah all right just making sure i know
which december okay
all right um
i don't know that it matters but i'm
just curious okay so
uh
well george you can chime in you you
just got married what would you do i
mean you got married a couple years ago
right yeah i would if if this is gonna
be a year or two away i'm gonna move out
and rent somewhere that's my that's my
take um that's just gonna give me a
feeling like i'm actually married and
like an adult and stuff and if it's a
real short period of time and you guys
need this it's okay but i don't think a
long-term plan is um to live with the
parents so how fast could you save up 20
on a house that you guys like because i
heard you say fall in love with and it
feels like you're looking for this
forever home and the truth is it's just
a box and find something that suits your
needs that you really really need but
you don't need to find this dream home
right now at 26 newly married
god well one of the things with the
grant that we're getting is that we have
to stay in the home for five years and
we kind of
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop what
kind of grant
it's a granted scheme provided here for
houston residents it's a first-time home
buyer
correct it's a fifteen thousand
i'll pass no thank you
okay alrighty then well anyway you know
why we're still obviously you know why
because you got to live in the house
five years
you're 26 years old you've been married
20 minutes
it's impossible for you to plan exactly
what's going to happen for five years
for a lousy 15 grand you make 120 you're
gonna let these people control your life
no thank you
the tail's wagging the dog man so i'm if
i'm you i'm looking for an apartment
right now
get a cheap apartment and save money for
a year um and like a crazy person set up
your life and then go make your down
payment on your house the truth is
there's no rule that says you have to
own a house as soon as you get married
and i know you guys feel like well this
is going to make us feel like adults but
right now you're living with your
parents so go rent for a year figure out
what area you want to live in what house
you want and be diligent about saving up
that down payment i want you guys to
save up 20 and avoid the pmi and uh you
know the parameters so you're going to
follow that and that's going to really
help you guys get on the right foot with
this marriage even if that's two years
from now i'm okay with you renting for
two years if it means getting into a
house the right way
yeah so guys let me just tell you we
work with all there's a lot of
government grant things out there
and uh there are a few
times that a government grant
has
a few enough strings attached to it
that it's okay to take it
but when we hear government grant all of
us initially until you've had a bad
experience or two with them
uh
me uh until you've had that experience
you you would say oh it's just free
money
but it's free money that comes with
handcuffs
and shackles the dumbest one i ever got
involved with was i was doing
renovations in my 20s when i was buying
houses buying selling houses
and i bought a historic house
in a historic area one of these
re-gentrified areas were going to
you know turn the hood into a
neighborhood again that kind of thing
and the beautiful old home beautiful
home and there was a historic grant
available
from the hysteric society
i mean the historic society
i thought you got that one wrong but i
realized it was a and it was five
thousand dollars which in in the in in
1980s 5000 was some money it was more
than 15 000 right
and so
but the grant stipulated that the house
had been put back
the way it was originally built to be
historically accurate
great that's what i was planning to do
anyway
then codes comes along
and says you have to put a rail on the
front porch
because since this house was built we
figured out people fall off the front
porches and break their face
so you cannot have a front porch this
high without without a thing and i said
great go tell the hysteric society that
you're requiring this
and i could not get these two
government people that was nice i was
try i cleaned that up that was
considered on the fly these two
government people to come into agreement
and in alignment because i didn't care
whether they put a rail up or not i just
wanted to free five thousand dollars
i spent
so much time and energy i finally just
told them stick it put the rail on the
porch and said i don't need your
hysteric society money and
you guys are nuts
you're requiring something that the law
doesn't allow in order to give a grant
now that's just asinine
but that's pretty typical when you get
involved in government grants and you're
going to get your foot caught in the
golden handcuffs
or your ear
or your neck
or something when you're screwing with
these dadgum grants and occasionally
there's one that doesn't have enough
nooses built onto it that it's worth
screwing it worth doing but man i'll
tell you what we've looked at them in
business we've looked at them remember
ppp loans oh yeah yeah there's a grant
wasn't it no it wasn't it was a loan
and some of you are paying that puppy
back now after we told you not to take
it
and everybody got real quiet about that
whole subject didn't they nobody talking
about that much
but we were yelling and screaming in the
microphone not to take that that they
were going to grab you guys around the
throat and that's exactly what's
happened to a bunch of you business
people out there yeah you now have a big
butt federal loan
so the lesson is uh if it has an if or a
butt attached to it it's a government
it's anyway that's what it is yeah the
if the gov if someone says i'm from the
scariest words in the english language
i'm from the government and i'm here to
help
yeah that's that's that's scary language
right there that should scare the pea
wadden out of you man so enough me
railing on the poor young guy he's just
trying to get a house but i'm not
picking on you jonathan you're a good
man congratulations on your marriage go
get you an apartment save you some money
buy a house son
don't don't try to trick your way into
this and for god's sakes george is right
there a stupid house there's one on
every corner get you a house that you
like but there's no such thing as a
forever home because you're forever
changes
you're forever changing
you know you had a forever home until
you got two dogs now it's not a forever
home anymore then we got three kids oh
my god it's for sure not a forever home
and then we're gonna move again into a
bigger house and call that our forever
home but it's not really you for never
home because your your your life changes
and goes through seasons so you're going
to go through seasons of change with
your with your house that's just uh very
few people buy a home i mean
statistically it's got to be less than
five percent and stay in it their entire
lives yeah it's just almost no one so
but newlyweds they get starry-eyed about
the home buying process exactly exactly
and we want you to get a house we just
don't want the house to get you so there
you go we certainly don't want the
government to get you
oh that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books thanks george camel
thanks james and kelly in the booth i'm
dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
you